oder was geht ab hier soll max und herz
willkommen zu einer runde götter und
zusammen mit mister get down mit richtig
mit re wie das geht
na was ist was ist schön bei dir
überrascht mich jetzt aber nicht wir
haben gerade ein super lustiges video
mit baby und wenig aufgenommen bitte ich
nehme die sind irgendwie relativ selten
auf der karte habe ich meinen ersten
kollnburg aufgesammelt muss ich mich
auch nicht schlecht ab nähe nicht
übermäßig also nicht schlechter als
sonst freundlich muss probieren
das war wie ein rewe irgendwie ein
bisschen was zurückzugeben weil ich
werde irgendwie regelmäßig in release
videos gemacht aber ist es so eine sache
von mir oder von mit dir in einem video
sein
warum ist es den abort rack server baby
hat mir gerade vor der aufgabe was
geklärt
und zwar könnt ihr meine lieben freunde
mit dem kran kräfte wird von mir zu
einfach vorgestellt
für euch 50 prozent rabatt auf premium
kriegen wenn ihr den und zwar 50 leute
also den zeitpunkt tv
ich war auch so mahne ich war ich war
acht punkt zur über und stand direkt vor
einem blogeintrag
der offizielle slogan diese offiziell
eigentlich mittlerweile nehme der
inoffizielle slogan für den server
stammt übrigens von keinem geringeren
als mir mein leben geschenkt das auch
was wert leider stimmt dann tut es mir
leid
kauft euch kein premium und dann kam
wird was heißt anfang was richtig gut
was war das meiste was du schon 1
punkten hat es wirklich gut konnte auch
alle tätig ist gemacht
hier kannst du insider informationen
geben was sind für teure updates geplant
ich bin richtig ja ich hab nicht mal 300
punkte mann ich habe 758 zwei neue
spielmodi
wann dies soweit ist dass welche erst
mal nicht verraten aber es gibt noch ein
ganz großes weihnachts update
beziehungsweise ein eventuelles updaten
nach weihnachten direkt das müssen wir
mal schauen lässt halte ich ihn bekommen
wo etwas ganz ganz einmalig großes und
tolles angekündigt wird und zwar mag
jetzt kommt zu ok du kannst auf dem
server kein scherz nicht nur party
feiern also sondern einer party ist ja
als ob kannst du auch mit deinen coins
alkohol kaufen und crystal meth hab ich
mir ausgedacht sie tatsächlich du hast
das plug-in gibt schon länger für dich
so für deine aufnahmen und jetzt geht es
für alle des iran sind gibt es
eigentlich probleme somit jugendschutz
ich habe auf jeden fall da nur an lucky
blöcke bekommen ja er wird richtig lang
also richtig spekuliert und natürlich
hatte ich so wie es verdiene ich glaube
ganz eventuell könnte es doch mit dem
lucky blockiert weil lucky blogs wird
dann auch ein bisschen glück dafür hast
du das glück scheint warum sich so
schnitt leistet das hasse ich diese
leute diese so richtig auf raschen
spielen die das sie walter weißt du ja
ich bin ich ganz gut baguette nicht
klappen oder enchantment bekommen
ich weiß zu essen gekauft man nicht
ich habe schlechte leisten
ja das ist aber ganz normal warum zum
booms kriege ich keinen schadens auf
mein schwert ich werde kein schwert ohne
schaden nehmen perfekt
nein warum
ja okay wer verbietet
ich verbiete es dir als würde ich ihr
verbieten sexuell mit meinem bruder zu
verkehren
was ich auch tue kein problem
okay was halt ich habe eine tolle zeit
ich habe anregung 30 43 und berg 24 sec
2 halt die fresse ich wirklich doch
schärfe eins drauf es soll auch schon
mal was wert oder
ich bin ja gespannt ist kann auch gut
sein ich gehe immer ein bisschen sehr
auf schwert das sich verpacken vor allem
bei der karte ist eine angel sowas von
op gutes bin so gespannt aus dem koffer
stecken kann es schon mal ist der typ
ist auf jeden fall leichte beute und du
versteckst du jetzt wirklich ganze zeit
ja jetzt kann man mal machen wir nicht
raus
noch bei 1 hatte der als du hey du hast
du schon mal im leben
ok dass wir nicht der eine wende am ufer
wo ist der andere als perfekte hat
deppen bogen auch noch mit flame der
andere richtung chef der andere ice
alter jetzt habe ich sehr schön hier
noch ein bogen bekommen alter die op ist
der bogen
doch power 41 ist das hier ja das ist
wegen noch berg 2 aber die runde suchte
ich finde wenn ich die finde ich dann
töten
okay doch ich musste doch nicht wo du
bist dass du sagst hier weil das war das
einzige fenster was ich von freunden aus
sehen konnte
tatsächlich bin ich dem fenster wenn
nicht du kannst mich sehen ganz mich
sehen ob man egal später gesehen kommt
was ein bisschen verloren und ist sogar
and nickt ja heute nicht verschont
davon dass der schiller 13 der erst mal
rankommen ich hab nicht mal wie man die
abos panzer ruth schiller und wieder gut
war so richtig hatte so richtig richtig
weh man dieser typ ist so penetrant mit
seinem ekligen weglaufen hör doch auf
wird ihr nichts bringt davon jetzt ja
jetzt besucht verloren so und welch des
schmerzes man ich hasse also diese
wasserkarte ist echt ein bisschen khaki
ist er kämpfen max euch zwei tatsächlich
da wo ich bin
wieso auch wie ich in pink stellen gebe
aber ich habe ein besseres schwert
bestimmt schon die ganze zeit von mir
weg glaube er weiß dass ich ihn schicken
kann
ich hoffe dein leben
ja es ist gut ich habe es verstanden
russischen teams nicht verboten oder
sitzt du diese regel außer kraft
von meg whitman okay okay ein paar
sachen werde ich ihn los
aber wenn ich jetzt dafür gebannt werden
was machen wir dann passiert nicht weil
ich ja da war ja im sommer holen so ein
reh wien zeit oder so hieß er hat mich
die ganze zeit beleidigt das war so
nervig ich konnte einfach nichts machen
weil der war so hässlich das ist richtig
kg was ihn gerade booms was ja klar ich
habe ihn getötet
da dachte ich diese rede war macht mich
diese richtig gehen macht nicht diese
ja es war nicht schlecht
ich war natürlich zugegebenermaßen auch
ein bisschen überrascht will dass du
bist unser bündnis wir brauchen hast das
schwimmteam zweifel möglich 810 verboten
okay
na gut dann was meine schuld aber
trotzdem die runde aber interessant wenn
einige special effects über mein
lieblingsspiel modus ist wirklich den
spielmodus herausgefunden und
krankhafter alles klein geschrieben 50
könnt euch